- I have always been
attracted to visionaries,
comedians and people who make me laugh.
I was so attracted to our next guest.
I even married him.
Yeah, (laughing)
(audience laughing)
'cause that's what you do.
Please welcome.
A wonderful, wonderful man,
Tom green.
(audience applauding)
- Hi Drew. (laughs)
Hi everybody. (laughs)
I brought Charlie with me.
Hello Drew, how are you?
- I'm--
- Nice to see you.
- I'm so good.
I know you have a new woman in your life.
(laughs)
- Yes. This is my new puppy, Charlie
and we were taken off on a van trip
and we're gonna travel
around the country together
and I'm really looking forward to it,
but great to see you
and congratulations on
your incredible show.
I'm so happy to be here.
And was so happy when you
invited me on the show.
Thank you so much.
This is amazing.
- I am little backstory for anyone
is that we haven't seen
or spoken to each other
in far too long.
- Thanks for having me here Drew
and I'm really, really
couldn't be more excited
about your new show.
It's nice to see you every day on here.
Just bringing this burst of happiness
and energy
and optimism
to the world right now.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- Dick and Mary Jane,
my mother and father,
they say hello by the way.
And they're really happy
that I'm here on the show
and they're happy for you.
And we're all really
happy for you actually.
We love watching you do amazing things
and we're so excited about your new show.
- I've had two nights of
great sleep in my life
before my daughters were born.
And I don't know why but sleep is like,
it's just been like a weird thing for me.
And I remember this night
just being so content
and I was at your parents' lake house.
And I remember hearing
all their voices upstairs
and I was just by myself
and I was going to sleep
And I was like, "yeah,
this is what you know
safety and contentedness feels
before you're going to sleep."
And I will never forget that night.
And I love your parents
and I really love you.
And I celebrate you.
And you know, when you say like, 20 years
it's sometimes it's a blink of an eye.
(laughs tearfully)
And sometimes you're like,
"Oh my God, we've lived so
much in these last 20 years."
You've had a whole life
and I've had a whole life
and it's just really nice to come together
and check in and talk about it.
It just, it thrills me to no end.
And I think the world of you
and I celebrate you and I
always have and I always will.
- Thank you Drew, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- This is a really...
I was so happy when you
invited me on the show.
It's been too long.
We should have, you know,
it's nice to reconnect.
We really did not talk for
about 15 years, I guess.
And this is really the
first time we've looked
at each other face to face in 15 years.
- One of the things that means so much
to me professionally also
is because one of the reasons
that we got to know each other
in the first place
was I admired your work so much.
And so I reached out to you
and asked you to come
and do Charlie's Angels.
And you so graciously said, "yes."
But that was so exciting
getting to do that movie with you.
And you know we kind of,
sort of hit it off right away
pretty much.
- Yeah.
- We had a lot of laughs together.
I think one of our first dates
I think we went bought lobsters,
'cause we both love animals
and we both got lobsters
and we released them
into the ocean.
That was what we decided to do.
- We did.
And you brought me a camera
and I still have it,
the Pentax K1000.
And you got me started
into what would become
you know, two decades full
of being a real photographer.
And you got me into my
whole Annie Hall phase
of taking photographs,
which is such a beautiful art.
And it tracks me back
to what you were doing
when you did it.
There was no technology available.
There was no internet.
There was like no cell phones.
There was no social media.
And you opened the
floodgates of all of it.
And you did it in this way
where you really messed with people,
but it wasn't mean, and it wasn't angry.
And when you can go that far
and push the envelope
to that degree--
- What'd you say about not being mean?
That that was always part of it.
I would never wanna do
something to someone
that was actually mean.
But if I went out and did
something really stupid
and they got mad at me,
that was the humor in it for me.
- I mean, did you start with a camcorder?
- I like tech, you know I'm a geek, right?
- Yes. (laughing)
- I like technology.
(laughing)
I like technology
and I like cameras and
computers and editing.
And I'm always playing
with the latest technology.
So, sometimes when you
see what the new camera is
or the new microphone
or the new editing
machine that's coming out,
you try to think how you're gonna do
something creative with that.
And then we just went out
and made this crazy show
and we were in our early 20s
and just were wild and ridiculous
and had a great time.
And I remember when MTV picked up the show
and moved me down to New York city,
how exciting it was.
And I remember you
called over to the studio
and that was very cool, very exciting.
(Drew laughs)
And then eventually when
I moved to Los Angeles,
I met you and we did Charlie's Angels.
And now travels with Charlie.
Maybe it makes sense
that The Chad would have a
dog named Charlie, right?
I'm The Chad.
- Yeees. (clapping and laughing)
(audience applauding)
You're The Chad.
- I'm The Chad.
I'm The Chad.
- It might be The Chad.
- I'm The Chad.
Good morning Starfish.
- Good morning The Chad.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)